bonjour
merci bon match c'est un protocole
obligatoire pour lancer le coup d'envoi
de toute rencontre de football
professionnel comme amateur le pass
annie terre des joueurs est exigée avant
d'entrer sur la pelouse c'est nécessaire
pour la protection tout le monde donc ni
fin quoi qu'il arrive vers l'est le
faire et c'est bien pour nous parce que
l'on peut rejouer au foot malgré le
bonheur de pouvoir enfin participer aux
compétitions l attente attendu coupe de
france certains restent mitigés quant à
l'impact de cette décision sortir son
téléphone se faire contrôler tout ça
gâche la beauté du sport je suis pas
trop pour ce dispositif est bon pour
faire avec ces des restrictions qu'on a
on doit les accepter c'est une perte de
joueurs aussi parce qu'il ya des joueurs
qui sont contre tout ce qui est vaccin
test donc on perd des joueurs aussi
juste que ce soit chez les adultes ou
chez les jeunes encore beaucoup plus
chez les jeunes parce qu'ils sont
dépendants de leurs parents cette perte
de joueurs pourrait devenir encore plus
préoccupante dans les semaines à venir
très prochainement les tests vont
devenir payant donc ça va être une autre
problématique forcément lorsqu'il y a
des des licenciés bas ça ramène bien
évidemment à l'aspect financier donc il
ya beaucoup de clubs qui risque
malheureusement de mourir une fois les
dépistages co vite devenu payant en
octobre les joueurs nous vacciner
devront payer entre 90 et 150 euros par
semaine pour pouvoir participer à tous
les entraînements et matchs de leur club
de football